Welcome to problem set 4. In this problem set, I'm going to write a random tester or fuzzer.
In our example, we're going to be fuzzing PDF files and our application is a couple of PDF readers.
This example is taken from Charlie Miller's fuzzer "Babysitting an Army of Monkeys."
I encourage you all to look at these sites.
To start this fuzzer, we begin by choosing a random file and choosing a random PDF application.
We then read in all the bytes from our file and store it in the buffer.
Next, we run a random function to determine the number of writes
that we are doing based on FuzzFactor.
Read up on this FuzzFactor to be 250, and you can see as the
FuzzFactor increases, the number of writes decreases.
Based on the number of writes, we create a byte, a random byte, and choose from our buffer
one of the bytes that we're going to overwrite.
We then overwrite that byte with a random one
and we continue to do that until we get to the number of writes.
Finally, we write all our new bytes to a file, a new file, so we don't overwrite our old one,
and we then uses a subprocess margin to open our application with our new file.
Now, when you run the script, you might see your program go crazy,
and if that happens, then you've done it correctly.
Now, there are few things I want to point out. This type of code is the heart of the fuzzer
This is all that you really need  for this program to work.
A couple of other things noticed that we don't do any logging.
This is bad practice for all programmers.
We should always do logging in your applications to make the bugging easier.
What I want you to do is write a fuzzer
based on the one that we gave you for real world applications.
In our example, we fuzzed has a PDF files.
After you bring your fuzzer, I want you to go to the forums and link to your fuzzer,
show what you fuzzed, describe any bugs that you found,
and explain how you would improve your fuzzer in the future.
Post all these things to the forum, and when you're finish, check this box.
Now, of course, you can check this box
without actually having done the problem set, but then, what will be the point.
Good luck on problem set 4.